fier d'annoncer que ce budget est le
budget équilibré le budget de l'aide à
ceux qui en ont pas besoin
on oublie les gens qui ont contribué à
l'atteinte du déficit zéro c'est un
projet qui est mort à l'aspiration il en
a beaucoup à voir des milliards pour les
mieux nantis de notre société et des
miettes pour la classe moyenne
alors retour sur ce budget qui donne
vraiment le coup d'envoi de la campagne
électorale un budget on l'a dit
équilibré pour la première fois en huit
ans est ce la clé pour que le
gouvernement conservateur garde le
pouvoir d'achat daniel et michel sont là
daniel etter dawa tâche à toronto michel
à montréal
bonsoir à vous trois bassins alors le
gouvernement a voulu faire plaisir à un
peu tout le monde dans ce budget daniel
qu'est ce que vous en retenez vous c'est
un fourre-tout électorale très bien
agencé par le gouvernement a peu à des
gens disaient ce l'après midi c'est un
budget en 35 à 40% de la population
ces gouvernements à peu a besoin pour
gagner la prochaine élection
écoutez vous trouverez pas dans ce
budget de grandes de direction à donner
à l'économie canadienne au cours des
années vous ne trouverez pas là tu as
une grande vision de ce que devrait être
l'économie du canada
ce que vous aviez trouvé là dedans c'est
un programme électoral premier ace après
son mini psy finançons racler le fond de
tous les tiroirs retrouver tous toutes
les salles noires qui traînent un peu
partout pour équilibrer leur budget mais
bon s'ils venaient à feu aux fesses que
ce que ce que ce qu'il devait faire
c'est-à-dire s'arranger pour gagner les
prochaines élections ce que tout premier
ministre à sa place auraient fait aussi
quand même des mesures d'achat pour les
aînés pour les aidants naturels c'est
pas un visage auxquelles monsieur
rappelé nous avait tellement habitués
basse etc les promesses tenues saupoudré
de compassion messieurs rapport acam et
on le voit
et écoutez c'est non seulement les
années il ya 2 millions $ pour le
commencement d'une stratégie sur
l'autisme
il y avait le fameux ces lits acquis qui
n'est pas seulement les aînés mais tous
qui sont proches de la retraite et c'est
ça qui est clé c'est une grande tranche
de la population qui peut être n'est pas
très bien antilles mais espère l'être et
c'est dans ce sens là les consommateurs
ont vraiment bien cibler leurs votes
ils ont aussi ciblé les petites
entreprises avec des coupures d'impôts
ce que le npd aimerait faire à
l'infrastructure comme les libéraux et
touche un peu les électeurs des deux
camps aussi pour les tenté de venir aux
conservateurs donc ils ratissent assez
large en fait michel avec la chute des
prix du pétrole on savait qu'ils les
revenus seraient moins élevés et
pourtant monsieur oliver a tout de même
tenu à atteindre l'équilibré budgétaire
à ce que c'était incontournable
d'un point de vue conservateur
politiquement par la seule était de
toute évidence
monsieur enlevée violée à peu près tous
les principes de prudence que les
conservateurs avaient invoqué dans les
années passées oui aux réserves qui est
indispensable complètement dilapidé ses
prévisions de croissance sont beaucoup
moins conservatrice que ce à quoi
monsieur clarté nous avait habitués donc
ils se sont dit c'est une promesse de
retour à l équilibre qu on ne peut pas
briser et je comprends c'est un peu
comme au québec d'ailleurs on peut pas
dire pendant des années c est effrayant
il faut absolument revenir au déficit
zéro pea dernières minutes avec touche
notre espace important alors
politiquement whissell était est-ce que
c'était souhaitable pour le canada ça
c'est une autre question observé deux
milliards de plus ou de moins sur un
budget de 300 milliards sari pas empêché
la tête de tourner sa ri.fr ou chez les
agences de notation et ça aurait
peut-être donner un petit coup de pouce
à l'économie canadienne au moment où
elle en a besoin
alors monsieur un peu a décidé que son
intérêt politique était le plus
important
sa chanson intérêts politiques écoutent
oui c'est sûr que ce serait une promesse
brisée mais aussi le fait que le canada
est un des pays économiquement qui sait
le pieux plus mieux tirés de la
récession de 2
8 et le signal qui est envoyé au marché
dans un moment où effectivement on a des
problèmes à cause du prix pétrole c'est
que l'église les finances sont
équilibrées le vraiment fait ses preuves
son travail et c'était un important
signal aussi triste ce débat pas ça va
tellement mieux qu'ailleurs qu'un atlas
ou de moins ça aurait pas fait une
grosse différence
ça aurait fait une différence aux urnes
certainement les mesures qui touchent
directement les contribuables auquel
elle entre en vigueur certaine dès
maintenant d'autres le chèque va arriver
au mois de juillet mais les autres
mesures comme les grosses mesures là
comme les investissements en
infrastructures pour la sécurité c'est
seulement en 2017 ce daniel way c'est le
chercher 0 les géniaux cité de ce budget
d'autres 0 à sochaux 6e d'hypocrisie
rawdon l'impression qu'on va dépenser
beaucoup d'argent dans beaucoup de
domaines des transports urbains par
exemple un milliard par année garantie
sauf que ça commence en 2006 finances de
l'ontario cet après-midi était furieux à
10 ans au smac 2 que le gouvernement
fédéral n'a rien compris qu'il ne
comprend rien aux besoins en transport
des grandes villes il est furieux aussi
parce que le gouvernement fédéral ne
comprend rien aux problèmes de santé
mais qui est celui des provinces qui va
en grandissant les choses ne vont pas
s'améliorer il n'y a rien de prévu de ce
côté là je vous donne juste l'exemple de
la défense on parle de quoi 10 ou 11
milliards au cours des dix prochaines
années
l'an prochain et 0,2 rare de prévue dans
2 ans 0 $ de prévu et dans trois ans 168
millions de dollars de primes non vie
battu les voir que c'est ta progression
très très très très très lente mais
châteauguay justement s'est passé la
même stratégie qu'ils ont faire 2011
pendant la campagne ils ont simplement
promis les crédits d'impôt pour les
familles le partage du revenu une fois
le budget équilibré et ce à plus de
quatre ans alors ses pieds dans l'eau
l'habitude de faire ses promesses les
mettre dans la vitrine et les faire dans
plusieurs années ici la population
n'aiment pas ça qu'ils votent pour ses
adversaires mais je pense pas avec la
situation qu'ils avaient le choix ils
n'auraient pas équilibrer le budget s'il
aurait financé ces projets-là
immédiatement et j'oubliais aussi si
vous permettez rapidement il ya une très
bonne nouvelle pour radio canada y à
5843 d'alors de plus
la bultière 5100 un peu d'ironie dans
votre propos non non je suis très
sérieux absolument pas dire oui bon
michel ça laisse quand même une marge
manoeuvre manuelle on parlait tout à
l'heure bien mince là pour l'opposition
comment contrer des mesures qui vont
quand même être populaire auprès de la
population
oui oui ça va être un problème très
certainement pour l'opposition déjà
monsieur mal qu'elle nous a dit que dans
son cas il était absolument pas question
de devenir un déficit donc il va être
obligé de composer avec cette marge de
manoeuve locke & key est très étroite
dans le cas de monsieur de monsieur mois
qu'elle lui a laissé une porte ouverte
mais monsieur trudeau a été a été très
très stricte là dessus très ferme
mais quand même monsieur trudeau devrait
mettre quelque chose sous la table mais
sont dit depuis des années pas
simplement dans sur la question
budgétaire mais il a aussi très très
clairement dit qu'il éliminerait le tout
petite histoire du fractionnement du
revenu ça ça dégage quand même un
certain nombre de milliards que monsieur
trudeau va pouvoir appliquer ailleurs
probablement une autre mesure fiscale
mais qui rate y serait beaucoup plus
large et qui s'adresserait pas seulement
des gens favorisés
je pense pas qu'il aille dans une
direction aux cette avancée un disque
par exemple la création d'un réseau de
garderies comme monsieur mode qu'elle
propose
mais il est clair que la marche de
l'opposition et rétrécit d'autant 7 du
gouvernement d'ailleurs craqué au hacker
vous êtes tous les trois des grands
amateurs de rock & roll qu on appelle ça
jouer la trappe s'était étouffé
l'adversaire complètement
il n'y a plus aucune marge de manoeuvre
et à la fin de la partie c'est le
gouvernement conservateur qui va voter
le budget
mais c'est ça la stratégie je dirais les
conservateurs en général c'est sûr que
ce se comporte pas comme un parti qui
est en faveur du petit gouvernement dans
les médias il donne de l'argent ici et
là mais dans le long terme qui vont
restreindre la capacité fiscale du
gouvernement parce qu'ils ont baissé la
tps
ils ont augmenté le celi ils ont fait
les autres mesures comme avec les dix
années qui vont réduire les impôts qui
vont revenir au gouvernement
ce qui empêcherait les gouvernements
futurs de faire de très grands
programmes sans augmenter les impôts
mais est-ce que
l'opposition quand même et enfin elle
est prise de court avec tout ça alors
comment ça va jouer tout comment ça va
comment le message des conservateurs va
passer dans la population c'est un
message plus clair peut-être que celui
de l'opposition partir de maintenant il
va y avoir un programme de publicité de
7 millions $ ou est ce que vous allez
voir cette publicité dans sur le budget
sur tous les bons coups du gouvernement
conservateur sur ces gestes à
l'international pendant les séries
éliminatoires de raquer grosse
population qui écoutent un mandat
d'écouté cetera et à partir du 1er
juillet les gens vont recevoir leur
premier chèque allocations familiales en
particulier bref la campagne électorale
a commencé le 1er juillet avec le
premier chèque avait doublé de vitesse
et puis on est parti pour la loire
jusqu'au 16 octobre
le fractionnement du revenu ça commence
les gens font leur rapport d'impôt ta
chérie
oui ça commence là et même si eto'o a
déjà dit qu'il changerait sai les
minerais ainsi que les styles y est il
ya dix ans aujourd'hui l'augmentation
alors c'est ça le savent mais
l'opposition un peu en position de
grincheux parce que c'est commencer à
retirer les bénéfices auxquels la
population devient habitué les gens vont
être très fâché alors c'est déjà fait
des choix très difficiles pour et les
libéraux et le npd
mais est-ce que ça clarifie pas quand
même le message de chacun des partis
michel binsse et clarifie surtout celui
des conservateurs sont liés clair que
tout le monde sait maintenant où il loge
et se rejoint on disait en début de 35 à
40% de l'électorat
c'est parfait c'est tout ce que visent
les conservateurs et si par ailleurs les
libéraux et les néo démocrates
commencent à chicaner pour savoir de
quelle île plus progressistes pour
lequel les moins c'est parfait pour les
conservateurs ce temps que les libéraux
il
néo démocrates se chicane pour le même
climat elle la même clientèle
monsieur harper passe entre les deux et
peut très bien peut espérer dans
seulement être élu mais possiblement
même avec une majorité
le mot de la fin d'achat ben c'est cette
majorité là parce qu'on a vu un sondage
qui est sorti aujourd'hui qui démontre
que s'il n'y a pas une majorité que une
majorité de canadiens sont en faveur
d'une coalition alors c'est certainement
cette majorité là qui est visé par ce
budget intéressant merci beaucoup à vous
trois pour ce panel exceptionnel à mardi
mais budget oblige merci beaucoup on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine jeudi
prochain comment ça